[Musik]
es hat sich ausgeloggt für die deutschen
zumindest hat urlaub in deutschland
nicht mehr viel mit entspannung zu tun
denn kaum einer blickt noch durch bei
den neuen chor ohne reise regeln
verunsicherung und chaos überschatten
die vorfreude und das pünktlich zu den
herbstferien
welche maßnahmen sind wirklich sinnvoll
und wie viel corona schutz verträgt
unsere wirtschaft eigentlich noch
[Musik]
darüber wollen wir jetzt diskutieren und
dazu begrüße ich bei mir im studio peter
altmaier bundeswirtschaftsminister cdu
ingrid hartges hauptgeschäftsführerin
dehoga dem bundesverband von gaststätten
und hotelgewerbe christian lindner fdp
chef und ralf stegner spd politiker
sowie wir sehen ihn noch nicht aber
manfred luger von den grünen
gesundheitsminister in baden württemberg
ja der neueste streich den sich die
politik gegen korona ausgedacht hat das
beherbergungs verbot wir haben uns mal
auf der nordseeinsel sylt umgehört und
ich kann sagen die meinung dazu die
gehen auseinander
die reinste koffer parade am bahnhof
westerland das friesische schietwetter
countries nicht von der beliebten reise
nach sylt abhalten
aber wie corona sicher kann man sich bei
den urlauber horden überhaupt noch
fühlen auf der insel
ich lebe hier
man merkt hier nach wie vor wenig davor
wir kommen aus dem kleinen ort
15.000 einwohner haben zwei
problemfelder zu hause fühle mich sicher
und hier bis jetzt auch ich habe schon
ein bisschen zeit das der fall ist
genau wie im rest schleswig holsteins
gelten auch hier auf sylt strenge
einreisebestimmungen wie er aus
risikogebieten anreist hat ohne einen
höchstens 48 stunden alten negativen
kommune test keine chance ich finde es
richtig denn ich denke die risikogebiete
die müssen für einen seite geschützt
werden auf der anderen seite müssen wir
auch geschützt werden für den
risikogebieten wenn es gerechtfertigt
ist das in ordnung
viele jungs aus berlin die wollten das
kommt wollten hier noch
in den kalten geht halten
eine stadt wie berlin 23
gewiss besser ist man ganz dicht machen
und wissen was machen muss man weiß
nicht wie das in der praxis funktioniert
genau so eine gemeinde grenze wohnen sei
normal rüber links und rechts mit
bildern irgendwann auch sagen wenn wir
vorher kommt und wohin nach einer party
in der nacht vom dritten auf den vierten
oktober mit einem corona infizierten
spitzt sich nun auch die lage auf sylt
zu behörden befürchten dass sich die
party zu einem super sprayer ereignis
entwickelt
[Musik]
er stieg dann der
bundesgesundheitsminister rät ja zu
reisen innerhalb deutschlands in den
herbstferien dann gibt es kollegen aus
bayern markus söder die sogar ganz davon
abraten überhaupt zu verreisen sie sind
zugeschaltet aus dem urlaub aus dem
heimischen wohnzimmer oder haben sie
sich getraut zu verreisen
nein ich bin hier auf usedom in
mecklenburg vorpommern
da kann man glaube ich ganz unbesorgt
hinreisen mecklenburg vorpommern ist
schließlich deutschland eines der länder
die besonders gut bisher durch die krise
gekommen sind wir haben vergleichsweise
wenig infektionen ich glaube ohnehin
dass das reisen nicht das problem ist
wir wissen ja inzwischen deutlich mehr
über das virus unter anderem wissen wir
dass nicht das reisen das problem ist
sondern mangelnder abstand nicht
einhaltung von hygieneregeln oder
verzicht auf die maske das sind die
themen große partys aber weniger das
verreisen zumal die hotels ja sehr
strikte hygieneregeln einhalten ich habe
das hier auf usedom gesehen da geben
sich die leute allergrößte mühe dass du
es auch eingehalten werden wenn die
leute sich an die regel halten dann
glaube ich ist das mit den reiseverboten
nicht die richtige maßnahme denn
eigentlich sollen die maßnahmen die
politik greift ja auch was zu tun haben
mit dem problem und das problem ist
nicht dass reisen sondern die verletzung
der regeln frau erdgas wir haben gerade
gehört das reisen nicht das problem da
wird sich mehrheitlich an die regeln
gehalten auch die hotels haben wirklich
viel implementiert um den größtmöglichen
schutz möglich zu machen
können sie es verstehen dass es jetzt
wieder die restaurant und hotel branche
trifft mehrheitlich mit den neuen regeln
das ist ganz bitter dass jetzt pünktlich
zur herbstsaison hier diese
beschränkungen erlassen wurden und
insbesondere das übernachtungs verbot
begegnet doch erheblichen rechtlichen
bedenken ist die maßnahme geeignet
erforderlich und verhältnismäßig im
rechtssinne wenn sie das nicht ist ist
sie rechtswidrig und ich gehe davon aus
das im nächsten tagen hier auch
gerichtsverfahren anhängig gemacht
werden und unabhängig davon muss man
natürlich auch sagen wenn man so was
macht was die mobilität der menschen
betrifft dann bedarf es einheitlicher
regelungen eines rechtsrahmens den mann
definiert wenn ein übernachtungs verbot
erlassen wird dann gibt es aber von
vornherein die und die ausnahmen dann
auch welche zeit punkte gelten ja also
für den test wie alt darf der test sein
wenn ich ein reise- oder wenn menschen
in manchen bundesländern dürfen sie sich
14 tage vorher nicht einem risikogebiet
aufgehalten haben in anderen
bundesländern sieben tage vorher nicht
also es versteht keiner diese
unterschiedlichkeit der regelung es gibt
eine vielzahl rechtlicher fragen und da
hätte ich mir gewünscht dass sowas auch
vorher mal diskutiert und erörtert wird
also erstens rechtliche bedenken
generell es wird klagen geben und zum
zweiten unabhängig davon müssen wir eine
bessere koordinierung der länder haben
und auch vorherigen intensiven austausch
mit uns herr altmaier die punkte würde
ich gerne beide doch an sie weitergeben
es gibt durchaus schon bedenken eben
auch ihr kollege wolfgang kubicki
stellvertretender chef der fdp warnt
bereits und sagte dass diese maßnahmen
beherbergungs verbot möglicherweise
verfassungswidrig sind
hat die kanzlerin gemeinsam mit den
länderchefs hier verfassungsbruch
beschlossen also erst mal der reihe nach
das überhaupt maßnahmen beschlossen
wurden sind hängt damit zusammen dass in
ganz europa die infektionszahlen
explodieren dass wir auch in deutschland
sehr stark gestiegen sind und wenn es
nicht gelingt diesen trend zu brechen
und rückgängig zu machen dann werden wir
in einigen wochen mit viel viel größeren
problemen auch in den intensivstationen
zu kämpfen haben zweitens bin ich bei
privates wenn wir maßnahmen ergreifen
dann müssen es auch die richtigen sein
und diejenigen die dazu beitragen können
die infektionskette zu brechen da ist
der erste punkt glaube ich der dass die
verfassungsrechtlichen kompetenzordnung
die besagt jedes bundesland entscheidet
selbst wie es damit umgeht nicht die
praxistaugliche ist denn diese pandemie
kennt keine grenzen
die menschen reisen in deutschland aus
beruflichen aus privaten aus
touristischen gründen zwischen den
bundesländern
und das bedeutet es muss zwingend eine
einheitlich und eine klare regelung
geben
damit jeder bürger weiß woran er ist und
ich habe es muss der bund wieder an sich
nein die länder können muss der bund
muss gar nicht immer kompetenzen an sich
ziehen dass das ist nicht mein fall
sondern ich meine nur dass die 16
bundesländer in der verantwortung stehen
sich gemeinsam zu einigen
wir haben ja ministerkonferenz in der
gesundheitsminister der bundesländer
wir haben treffen der bundeskanzlerin
mit den ministerpräsidenten
und dort muss allen ländern klar sein
sie können nicht auf ihrem auf ihrem
eigenen standpunkt beharren egal was
andere tun sondern müssen sich einigen
und das habe ich eben kritisiert das
muss ich auch aussprechen dürfen wir
haben als es vor ein paar monaten 300
infektionen pro tag gab
da haben viele gesagt das kann man jetzt
riskieren dass die länder eigene und
unterschiedliche maßnahmen ergreifen
inzwischen steigen die infektionen in
allen ländern wieder an die zahl der
hotspots hat sich vielfältig viele
menschen sind verunsichert und deshalb
brauchen wir ein einheitliches vorgehen
und was mir ganz wichtig ist war ja die
meisten bundesländer heute schon gesagt
haben wenn du aus einem risikogebiet
kommst in deutschland musste diesen test
vorweisen nicht älter als 48 stunden
das halte ich für vertretbar aber nur
dann wenn sichergestellt ist dass jeder
der so einem test braucht ihn auch
bekommen kann und zwar rechtzeitig
bekommen kann dann kann man mit einer
solchen maßnahme die risiken eindämmen
wenn aber die menschen von pontius nach
pilatus laufen müssen um so ein test zu
bekommen und die nachher am ende
vielleicht doch nicht kriegen dann sehe
ich da ein großes problem da vor uns ich
land genau das ist der fall wenn er
später noch mal mit einem kollegen
sprechen da aber jetzt noch mal kurz auf
die verhältnismäßigkeit die sie eben
auch schon angesprochen haben herr
lindner ist da maß und mitte noch
gewahrt bei diesen neuen regeln
sperrstunde alkoholausschank verbot und
eben beherbergungs verbot
herr altmaier hat ja recht mit der
forderung nach einem einheitlichen nach
einem einheitlichen vorgehen in
deutschland aber nicht gesagt welches
und da möchte ich gerne mal meine
meinung sagen ich bin für eine
einheitliche vorgehensweise in
deutschland für vergleichbare regeln
aber die einschränkung von freizügigkeit
und das beherbergungs verbot die sind
zum jetzigen zeitpunkt unverhältnismäßig
und unnötig also einheitliche regeln ja
aber dann müssen es auch die richtigen
seien regeln die für die menschen
nachvollziehbar sind und tatsächlich
auch zum jetzigen infektionsgeschehen
passen erst wird merken zweite bemerkung
ich wehre mich dagegen dass wir
ausschließlich schauen auf die zahl der
neuinfektionen
herr altmaier wir sind doch längst viel
weiter selbst der chef der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung und
viele epidemiologen und biologen sagen
wir müssen doch schauen wer zum beispiel
von einer neuen infektionen betroffen
ist wenn es menschen vermehrt in
altenpflegeheimen wären dann hätten die
alarmstufe rot aber jetzt sagt die
demographie es sind überwiegend jüngere
menschen ja aber die man so will den
punkt er noch zu ende machen es nicht
mein einziger vorschlag die situation
des öffentlichen gesundheitsdienstes
muss man ansehen wie ist die belegung in
den krankenhäusern
wie ist die situation in den arztpraxen
und dann sagen praktiker wie gesagt der
chef der kassenärztlichen
bundesvereinigung mit den 4000 praxen
die er vertritt er sagt eine kurze
zwischen der serbien haben wir der
andreas gassen vorstandsvorsitzender der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung sagt
wir müssen aufhören auf die zahl der
neuinfektionen zu starren wie das
kaninchen auf die schlange das führt zu
falschen alarm ist munter hat er ja auch
recht
es geht nicht darum zu verharmlosen aber
die alleinige konzentration auf die neue
infektion wie das auch herr söder heute
getan hat das ist nicht richtig ich
glaube wir müssen auf andere maßnahmen
setzen für gene und abstand im alltag
herr altmaier endlich eine test
strategie schnell und günstig tests für
die menschen schutz beispielsweise von
sehr gefährdeten gruppen menschen in
altenpflegeeinrichtungen beispielsweise
aber keine pauschalen maßnahmen die die
freiheit der menschen zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt unverhältnismäßig einschränkt
gefeiert maier sepp tanzer
er schüttelt den kopf ich würd sie gehen
auch mal mit den vorschlag diesen
schwellenwert von 50 pro 100000
neuinfektionen anzuheben eben von herrn
gassen der sagt es wird auch viel mehr
getestet inzwischen wir müssten da
diesen schwellenwert vielleicht anheben
und auch andere faktoren mit einfließen
daran gelegen da bitte ich um
verständnis
ich bin der wirtschaftsminister nicht
der gesundheitsminister und ich halte
sehr viel davon dass diese frage von
ärzten und von den zuständigen auch
beantwortet wird aber ich will alles
richtig stellen niemand schaut nur auf
die zahl der neuinfektionen aber richtig
ist lieber herr lindner
wir hatten den ganzen sommer über sehr
viele junge menschen die sich angesteckt
haben bei partys und bei urlauben und
diesel altersdurchschnitt sich wieder
ein paar jahre erlauben es partys und
ohne haben gesagt ja bei partys die auch
bei urlauben dann stattgefunden wenn ein
junger mensch sagen ja mal haben die
veranstaltung ja partys sind personen so
und und dann haben wir festgestellt
waren jüngere und damit waren die
krankheitsverläufe nicht so schwer
nun stellen wir fest mit dem anstieg der
infektionen auf rund 400.000 pro tag
steigt auch wieder das
durchschnittsalter der betroffenen und
damit steigt auch wieder die zahl der
todesfälle noch auf einem niedrigen
niveau
wir waren vor einigen wochen bei zwei
toten pro tag gehört jetzt sind wir
wieder bei zehn toten
ja da kommen wir ja gerne dazu ich sag
nur diese pandemie ist für viele
menschen eine schwere bedrohung ihrer
gesundheit und auch ihres lebens ältere
erkrankte auch jüngere wenn sie
vorerkrankungen haben und deshalb müssen
wir uns schon darum kümmern so die
wirtschaft da will ich eine ganz klare
aussage machen
wir haben gelernt aus den letzten sechs
monaten wir wissen heute was gefährlich
ist und nicht und deshalb gibt es
überhaupt keinen grund für einen zweiten
generellen lockdown das sage ich auch
überall wo ich hinkomme
wir haben ja beim ersten lok dann auch
nicht die wirtschaftliche produktion
gestoppt wir haben wir haben nicht den
einzelhandel was lebensmittel angeht
gestoppt und heute wissen wird der
einzelhandel ist generell nicht das
problem
wenn sie in ein restaurant gehen oder in
ein hotel gehen wo die hygieneregeln
eingehalten sind ist auch das nicht so
dass man muss genau differenzieren da
bin ich ganz bei ihnen
und dann muss der politiker natürlich
auch den mut haben das zu benennen was
gefährlich ist und wir müssen es den
menschen sagen eine kurze nachfrage hand
aufs herz einen zweiten lok toren wird
es nicht geben das wird ja nicht von mir
alleine entschieden sondern von 16
ministerpräsidenten von der
bundesregierung ich sage als jemand der
den ersten aus voller überzeugung
mitgetragen hat wir haben so viel
gelernt dass wir zielgerichtete
maßnahmen ergreifen können und das sind
vor allen dingen maßnahmen die sich auf
feiern auf partys auf wo menschen auf
engstem raum zusammen sind wo keine
masken getragen werden beziehen aber ich
sehe keine veranlassung und keinen grund
über einen allgemeinen locker und
nachzudenken oder zu entscheiden aber
genau was jetzt gesagt haben ist ja
völlig richtig nur die hast das
beherbergungs geburt dazu gerne mutter
zu werden jetzt mal überlegen den
fünften der fusion unter brot aber hier
sind wir so viele teilnehmer und jeder
muss einmal zu wort kommen und wir haben
auch den gesundheitsminister aus baden
württemberg herrn luca hier der ja diese
beherbergungs verbotsmaßnahmen mitträgt
in der regierung in baden württemberg
und da würde ich jetzt gerne mal sie
fragen der spd gesundheitsexperte karl
lauterbach der ja selbst teilweise von
kollegen als chef apokalyptiker
beschrieben wird selbst der sagt diese
verbote sind drangsalieren willkürlich
und epidemiologisch völlig sinnlos was
treibt die landesregierungen an sowas
einzuführen
vielleicht haben manche vergessen dass
die großen krisen waren reiserückkehrer
aus den winterferien und karnevalisten
die durch die republik gereist sind und
herr lindner hat eine zahl nicht parat
gehabt wir haben jetzt bei den tests
eine positiv quote
von 3,8 prozent wir hatten bis vor
kurzem immer unter einem prozent wir
haben eine exponentiell steigende anzahl
und genau das ist der grund warum der
auch derzeit das mittel der
beherbergungs verbote 16 länder übrigens
lieber herr linden auch der von mir sehr
geschätzte kollege gar aus schleswig
holstein die ja sogar noch weiter
gegangen waren mit quarantäne
also da muss man schon sehr aufpassen
wenn man da irgendwelche zuweisungen
macht unser tatsächliche botschaft ist
und dass wir haben ja das beherbergungs
verbot schon seit dem sommer begonnen
sie haben es vielleicht vergessen mit
gütersloh weil wir dann einfach die
botschaft aussenden wollten wenn man aus
einem risikogebiet kommt auch nicht noch
touristisch zu reisen ich gebe ihnen
recht wir müssen gemeinsam mit dem
gesundheitsminister kolleginnen und
kollegen aber auch die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz sich
verständigen auf eine einheitlich
verständliche vorgehensweise ich möchte
noch was sagen zudem immer einheitlich
wir haben uns entschieden herr altmaier
und das war glaube ich oder große erfolg
dass wir nur noch regionale
beschränkungen machen wir haben regeln
aufgestellt dass wir nur die städte die
regionen also wir baden württemberg mit
einem 3 gestuften programm ab 10 ab 35
ab 50 im übrigens ich verstehe auch in
gassen nicht ich empfehle noch entrosten
sein interview dass derzeit jede
neuinfektion ist der zukünftige
exponential multiplikator für nächste
infektionen die ja gerade jetzt diffusen
bereich im planten bereich symptomfrei
mit einer wesentlich höheren mobilitäts
rate der menschen als wir sie in der
lock down phase hatten deswegen ist es
durchaus verständlich dass wir jetzt
appellieren
so wenig wie möglich sich mobilitäts
mäßig zu bewegen alles andere gebe ich
indirekt regeln alles einheiten
wir müssen auch feucht und fröhlich sie
sind auch die fragen nach temporären
alkohol verboten in den zonen wo wir
mehr als 50 infizierte haben weil wir
alles tun und tun wollen damit wir den
lockdown im größeren stil verhindern und
nur regional reagiert doch bei aller
liebe aber das was jetzt beschlossen
wurde verbote und maßnahmen das ist ja
mehr als nur appelle und man muss ja
auch darauf achten was das ganze
bedeutet dann für die leuten der leute
die betroffenen und st stehen
kernregionen da würde ich gerne mal
einen sehr prominenten vertreter ihrer
branche mit in die diskussion holen
alfons schuhbeck den starkoch der uns
sitzt zugeschaltet sein sollte herr
schuhbeck herzlich willkommen
was können sie denn wirklich wie sie
servus nach bayern nach münchen
so können sie berichten wie diese neuen
regeln sich jetzt auf sie auswirken auf
ihr auf ihrem betrieb auswirken das ist
immer sehr stark weil wir also ich bin
ja am platzl in münchen und wir seinen
reihen touristischer platz und aber
heuer sondern malt da da wir keine
touristen hatten zumindest keine
internationalen touristen es ist
natürlich für die gastronomie für die
komplette innenstadt
ich möchte sagen ein desaster aber wie
mich vielleicht ein bisschen was anderes
sagen
also man redet ja immer über über
beschränkungen das der fall ist es nicht
aber ich möchte mir auch einen appell an
die leute richten wenn sie sich
ausgewogen gesund ernähren schauen dass
sie immun system mittel nach oben
bringen dann haben wir eine andere waffe
auch gegen diesen virus wie die eben nur
verlasse auf andere und sorgt dort
definitiv waren das ja wir auch nicht
machen da das ist alles okay aber ich
muss an mir selber auch arbeiten muss
halt themen maske tragen muss dann
trocken heute masken wenn wir alle
zusammenhalten würden dann wären wir
vielleicht schon wieder etwas weiter und
wenn wir natürlich extra irgendwo mit
500 leute zusammen stehen
provozieren so erreiche ich gar nichts
können sie dass dieser von dem sie
gerade gesprochen haben noch mal kurz
schildern das ist ja teilweise existenz
wohnt in ihrer branche was wären sie da
von kollegen und wie geht es ihnen
selbst
na ja also ich wir sind alle betroffen
aber man muss halt auch schauen dass man
an sich selber arbeitet schauen dass man
versucht zusammen aus dieser sache
möglichst gut auszukommen und nicht
immer nur sagen doch mal hin zur diesmal
kaputt ist man ja auch gewisse
motivation dazu
also ich bin immer dafür wenn ich mich
ausgewogen gesund ernähre ein bisschen
schade dass meine kollegen mein umfeld
stimmt und das jeder machen würde dann
wären wir in der gesamtsituation einfach
weiter und nicht wenn man das sagt ist
er will jetzt darf man nicht sagen wir
mal wenn ich am flughafen gebe ich mein
ticket rein muss ich abstand halten ist
die fliegerei
da sitzen alle zusammen gegen die s bahn
oder in die u-bahn stehen alle bein
beinamen bin ich in einem restaurant was
wir eine auf steht die maske und sind
bin ich fertig bin kann wieder
hinzusetzen conti masken wieder
unternehmen also für die leute ist es
schon auch ein wirrwarr deutlich ist es
dürfen sie da sind sie auf dem pult
zusammen
dort feiern 1000 leute da sagt keiner
was und dann werden also mir kommt
manchmal vor es werden wie in der
gastronomie die buhmänner wären ja also
mir halten uns wirklich an diese regeln
und versuchen auch die einzuhalten und
die anderen leute zu motivieren oder die
man zu schimpfen erfolge jetzt muss man
zusammenhalten und immer uli zahn heute
da kann man auch mehr erreichen wenn man
sagen und da ist ja auch steht und dass
der student ist es auch nicht jeder
einzelne ist eigentlich mit schuld dass
man da weiterkommen an der situation
letzte frage dazu herr schuhwerk weil
sie gerade gesagt haben wir kommen uns
vor wie die buhmänner hat man das gefühl
in der hotel und gaststättenbranche dass
man drangsaliert wird und an anderer
stelle möglicherweise falsch weggeschaut
wird bei ansammlungen von partys die aus
dem ruder laufen also also ich kann das
jetzt nicht sagen also bei uns
geht sehr gesittet zu also wir haben da
überhaupt keine probleme auch mit der
behörde haben die probleme nicht
aber wie gesagt es müssen heute anderen
auch mitmachen wenn sie sagen ich sie
extra die maske nicht auf ich gehe jetzt
darüber weil weil weil da stehen schon
100 leute sowieso zum teil an der isar
in münchen dass man extra provoziert da
halte ich gar nichts davon leiden der
molli mit ernannt und vom der mann auch
nix je schneller wir versuchen dort
heraus zu kommen und miteinander sich
anständig zu benehmen
umso leichter haben es später oliver
dominant vielen dank herr schuhbeck sie
haben gerade massiv den kopf geschüttelt
als es um die nachvollziehbarkeit der
regeln ging
sehen sie nicht diesen punkt das ist
teilweise für die bürger ein bisschen
schwer zu begreifen ist dass man braucht
kraft die maske trägt im flugzeug aber
soweit dann getränke verteilt sind jeder
nimmt die maske ab und dringe
ja das ist ein punkt ist ein punkt der
ist in der tat erklärungsbedürftig ich
habe übrigens nicht nur den kopf
geschüttelt ich habe auch genügt
mehrfach
es ist nur so die grundregel die ist in
dem punkt ja für alle gleich
man muss die maske aufsetzen wenn der
abstand weniger als ein meter fünfzig
ist das heißt wenn sie dicht an dicht in
der s bahn stehen oder im bus sitzen
dann müssen sie die maske auf haben auch
wenn sie im flugzeug sitzen und dann ist
die frage was geschieht wenn dann
getränke oder essen serviert wird in der
tat das muss mit den medizinern
diskutiert werden aber es ist so dass es
trotzdem viel unklarheit gibt was
richtig und was falsch ist und da wo ich
den kopf geschüttelt habe war als
schuhbeck gesagt hat die menschen müssen
jeder ein bisschen vernünftiger sein
das ist ja richtig aber es gibt halt
eben auch viele unvernünftige und
deshalb unterstütze ich markus söder der
gesagt hat wenn es masken verweigerer
gibt dann muss man auch hart
durchgreifen dann muss man auch
bußgelder verhängen und jahres
unterstütze ich glaube dass wir ein
signal brauchen und dass man das
richtige gesagt hat im übrigen hat sich
ja in münchen auch gezeigt dass man
durchaus gegen das virus auch vorgehen
kann
münchen war von sehr stark steigenden
infektionszahlen betroffen
vor etwa 14 tagen drei wochen die
regierung und die stadt haben maßnahmen
ergriffen mehr masken pflicht weniger
alkohol ausgabe zu später stunde und das
ergebnis war die infektion sind wieder
deutlich zurückgegangen
herr altmaier dann noch mal nachgefragt
250 euro sachsen anhalt ist ja schon
ende august bei 50 euro nicht
mitgegangen sind sie optimistisch dass
das bundesweit umzusetzen ist ja darüber
müssen wir diskutieren es gibt ja
regelmäßig besprechungen der
ministerpräsidenten
und ich würde mir sehr wünschen dass
markus söder seinen vorschlag den ich
für nachvollziehbar und für vernünftig
halte dass er diesen vorschlag dann auch
im kreise seiner kollegen mit bespricht
und mit vertritt wir haben eine
situation im augenblick wo wir nichts
zulassen können dass die vielen die
vorsichtig sind gefährdet werden durch
einige wenige die bewusst provozieren
oder sich bewusst diesen dingen
verweigern
das ist glaube ich eine ganz ganz
notwendige konsequenz da haben wir noch
ein kleines video das gucken wir uns
gleich an aber zunächst noch mal an sie
die frage weiter gerichtet die fdp
unterstützt siehe 250 euro ist alles das
ist gar nicht jetzt jetzt mal ein
entscheidender punkt ich glaube wir
müssen differenziertere maßnahmen finden
wir haben ja eben aus baden württemberg
ein minister von den grünen gehört hier
in berlin regieren die grünen mit hier
wird ein wochenende der clubkultur
ausgerufen
die grünen tragen einen senat mit der
sich verweigert die unterstützung der
bundeswehr im gesundheitsdienst in
anspruch zu nehmen um infektionsketten
nachzuverfolgen und jetzt hören die
familien die uns hier verfolgen die
sollen jetzt an baden württembergischen
minister von den grünen
der sagt einer familie die vorsichtig
ist die maske trägt und die mit ihren
zwei kindern in den schwarzwald in
urlaub fahren wollte denen sagte ihr
dürft nicht kommen ich glaube da stimmt
etwas mit der politischen verantwortung
zuordnung nicht die priorität muss sein
unkontrollierte massenansammlungen die
wir sie hier in berlin gesehen haben die
müssen unterbunden werden inklusive der
verweigerung der maske weil das erlaubt
anderen menschen sich auch frei bewegen
zu können
deshalb ist auch alleine nur das schauen
auf neuinfektionen
nicht sinnvoll und richtig gerade dann
wenn es nur eine einzelne gruppe
insbesondere jüngere menschen sind die
betroffen sind
stichwort partys es gibt da sehr schöne
bei aus welcher aus naja kommt darauf an
ob die perspektive aber es gibt ein paar
interessante bilder aus berlin von
samstagabend man jetzt halten wir erst
zu meiner kollegin céline koch die sich
nämlich umgehört hat in berlin-kreuzberg
glaube ich bis der zellen bei den
partywütigen was kannst du berichten
hast du mal nachgefragt ob man sich dort
über die sperrstunde aufregt ja carina
bei dem party würdigen das ist ein gutes
stichwort genau die habe ich nämlich
ehrlich gesagt erwartet aber ich glaube
hier hinter uns ist wirklich gerade noch
am meisten los hier in kreuzberg ich
habe mal von vorne an als wir haben
angefangen mit einer taxifahrt wirklich
relativ wild war weil wir wollten alles
sehen wir sind durch die torstraße also
in berlin-mitte da war in den letzten
tagen wirklich ganz viel los
riesenschlangen vor den bars heute nicht
und jetzt sind wir hier in kreuzberg wie
du gerade auch gesagt hast mich der
kameramann versucht jetzt mal hier zu
schwenken
wir haben da hinten späti der ist
normalerweise auch rappelvoll es ist
wenig los und der taxifahrer das war
auch ganz spannend als er nämlich
mitbekommen hat über was wir hier heute
sprechen wollen über die sperrstunden
hat ja wirklich in seinem lenkrad so
genuschelt pandemie 20 20 wir kriegen
nicht mal so eine leichte grippe ähneln
was soll das mit den ganzen sperrstunden
als ich dann gesagt habe gilt als
interviewer haben gesagt in den er vor
die kamera möchte ich nicht und genau
das ist das problem die leute die jetzt
hier die chance dazu gehabt hätten vor
die kamera zu kommen und wirklich ihre
meinung zu sagen
die haben sich nicht getraut
interessantes weiteres interview war mit
dem kiosk besitzer von dagegen über der
hat mir erzählt dass vor allem gestern
und vorgestern super viel alkohol bei
ihm gekauft wurde er hat die leute
gefragt wo werden die das trinken sie
haben geantwortet die werden sich jetzt
zu hause verbarrikadieren es werde auf
jeden fall illegale partys hier weiter
stattfinden
aber wahrscheinlich eher zu hause also
hier auf der straße ist wirklich fast
gar nichts mehr los vor wenigen minuten
waren hier noch ganz viele tische die
sind auch wieder zugeklappt worden
da jemand der dinge erst mal hier mitten
aus kreuzberg berlin vielen dank für
deine eindrücke ist ist natürlich auch
sonntagabend vielen dank
hoffentlich jetzt einen schönen
feierabend wir gucken aber nochmal auf
bilder von gestern von samstagabend und
da sah das ganze doch etwas anders aus
und zwar wurde in einem club revier süd
ost ich weiß nicht wer von ihnen hier in
der 100er möglicherweise schon mal war
ordentlich gefeiert ohne abstandsregeln
ohne masken und genau das ist
möglicherweise das problem denn viele
infektionsherde gehen ja genau auf
solche veranstaltungen zurück auf
ausufernde familien partys feiern
hochzeiten geburtstage bei denen keine
regeln eingehalten werden oder auch eben
solche partys also möglicherweise haben
wir ja bereits genug regeln sie werden
nur nicht eingehalten herr stegner wenig
deutschland ist doch bis jetzt im
vergleich zu anderen ländern
ausgezeichnet durch die krise gekommen
und woran liegt das das liegt daran dass
ich den menschen an die regeln gehalten
haben
ich habe den eindruck dass wir die
akzeptanz der bevölkerung verlieren wenn
wir da wo eingegriffen werden müsste es
nicht tun und verschiedene regeln
ländern haben die man den menschen nicht
mehr erklären kann in unterschiedlichen
bundesländern
ich halte uns auf wenig davon wenn sich
einzelne profilieren in corona
wettbewerb wer hat die schärfste
regierung das bringt es nicht wir
brauchen einheitliche und klare regeln
und da wo rücksicht nicht genommen wird
wovor sich dann um sich nicht herrschen
da muss dann auch eingegriffen werden so
dass alle das sehen das ist extrem
rücksichtslos andere zu gefährden
es reicht ja ein aber so eine
massenveranstaltung um praktisch eine
katastrophe auszulösen man das muster
finde ich deutlich ging vorgegangen
werden aber regelung die niemand
versteht die man den leuten nicht
erklären kann
die senken die akzeptanz oder sind wir
ganz schnell eine situation wo
deutschland schlechter davor als ich
finde also wir könnten noch ein bisschen
aus dem lernen
jetzt ein halbes jahr gesehen haben dass
hier ganz gut funktioniert unser
gesundheitswesen funktioniert die
menschen sind weitgehend vernünftig die
regeln waren einfach und wurden
eingehalten
und deswegen brauchen wir keinen
regelungs wirrwarr
aber vielleicht ist es in der tat so
dass wir da wo man sieht dass trotz los
gehandelt wird dann auch entsprechend
konsequent durchgegriffen
da muss der staat am ende auch das
durchsetzen was im interesse des
gesundheitlichen wohls der
gesamtbevölkerung erforderlich ist wenn
wir das nämlich nicht tun dann sind wir
wirklich in ein paar wochen noch ganz
anders und herr altmaier hat folgendes
wird kein zweiter block da und geben das
hoffe ich auch aber das beruht eben auf
der frau auf der vorher aussicht dass es
eben auch passiert und eingehalten wird
und noch mal regeln müssen klar und
einfach allgemein verständlich sein dann
werden sie akzeptiert sonst geschieht
das nicht und da sehe ich schon ein
problem indem in den wettbewerb gehen
wir jetzt teilweise sehen und wo die
menschen gar nicht mehr verstehen warum
das eine so enorm dass andere anders
sind und partys und
massenveranstaltungen müssen halt in
gottes namen warten das ist das deutlich
kleinere übel als wenn wieder deutlich
mehr menschen erkranken auch schwer
erkranken menschen sterben müssen weil
andere rücksichtlos sind das geht so
nicht man schaue in die usa da kann man
sehen wie die dinge sich entwickeln
können wenn sogar schon die staatsspitze
rücksichtslos ist wir haben daraus ein
anderes system und deswegen rate ich
dazu einfach regeln die einheiten und
vorgehen gegen die die rücksitze sind
frau hat gerade gehört herr stegner hat
ganz deutlich angesprochen dass eben
dort ja eigentlich schon genug regeln
existieren aber nicht eingehalten werden
was hören sie da aus ihrer branche fühlt
man sich da so ein bisschen als
bauernopfer also jetzt wird wieder hotel
gaststätten branche weiter reglementiert
und dabei wochenende für wochen in der
man sieht ist die bilder von partys man
hört die nachrichten von familienfeiern
die ausufern und die dann zu lokalen
infektionsherden werden das fernseh da
also ich glaube man muss erstmal
differenzieren also ein risikogebiet
wird ja heute
erklärt wenn der inzidenz wert 50
überschritten wird es gibt aber auch zum
beispiel fälle wo das ausbruchsgeschehen
lokalisierbar ist wenn es in der
fleischwirtschaft bei erntehelfern oder
einem pflegeheim aufgetreten ist und hat
ja auch schon in bayern der
verwaltungsgerichtshof entschieden
also da muss denn keine maßnahmen
getroffen werden weil die
infektionsketten sind nachvollziehbar
und deswegen muss eben dieses festhalten
incidents wert 50 das muss jetzt mal
begründet werden erklärt werden brauchen
wir zusätzliche parameter hier in berlin
gibt es ja noch eine ampel
wieso gibt es hier nicht woanders also
gut dann auch auf die auslastung der
krankenhäuser abgestellt wird also hier
muss besser erklärt werden
das verbot ist eine katastrophe genauso
wenn auch einzelne städte münchen da
haben die wirte mir erzählt 50 bis 90
umsatzrückgang in der hotellerie genauso
was meinen sie was unsere betriebe jetzt
am donnerstag freitag samstag erlebt
haben eine stornierungswelle
ohnegleichen und und die gäste sind auf
maximal verunsichert und frustriert will
kommt an dieser stelle für den schaden
auf wäre schön wenn die
ministerpräsidenten dazu auch eine
antwort geschrieben hätten oder auch die
datenschutzrechtlichen fragen bezüglich
des corona test ist ein persönliches
gesundheitszeugnis darf der hotel jeder
von kopie machen also da sind ganz viele
fragen einfach im moment ungeklärt und
mit seinem aktionismus kriegen wir keine
akzeptanz ian meine branche hat
mehrheitlich super super mitgemacht wir
haben im august 50 millionen
übernachtungen in deutschland gehabt ich
kenne keinen einzigen infektionsfall das
rk ii hat zahlen veröffentlicht von ende
februar bis mitte juli schon ab saison
ja sind 55.000 cupid 19 fälle untersucht
worden da wurden nur 1,6 prozent der
fälle einem ausbruchsgeschehen in der
gastronomie und hotellerie bundesweit
zugeordnet das sind die mir letzten
bekannten zahlen zu süß und ich finde
wenn jetzt hier solche maßnahmen und
dann noch in seiner geschwindigkeit und
koordiniert ergriffen werden wo viele
menschen sich hier auf den urlaub
gefreut haben im eigenen land jens spahn
hatte ja auch noch dazu aufgerufen ja
also da ist denn
maximaler enttäuschung da viele
ungeklärte rechtsfragen also so kriegen
wir keine akzeptanz und abschließend
noch zum föderalismus der föderalismus
hat in unserem land unglaubliche starten
und ich finde auch insgesamt haben bund
und länder vieles gut auf weg gebracht
hat betrifft auch die soforthilfen die
stelle auf weg gebracht wurden jetzt die
überbrückungshilfe klar wir haben kritik
im detail aber man muss auch anerkennen
was da auf weg gebracht wurde
nur ich sag mal wenn jetzt hier und das
ist ja praktisch in mecklenburg
vorpommern ja hier für zehn millionen
menschen im land ist das ja ein
reiseverbot ja dass musik komme ich hin
muss negativ test haben sonst sage ich
ja gar nicht einreisen und dann muss
sich fünf tage in quarantäne
im zweiten test machen und dann ist man
urlaub schon vorbei also das ist
faktisch einreiseverbot und wie gesagt
ich bitte um maß und mitte und wir
lernen alle jeden tag dazu und die
politik betrifft auch ganz viel neuland
wie wir sehen auch am 17 oktober noch
und deswegen ist es wichtig hier muss
jetzt nachjustiert werden damit sie
nicht wieder reinholen sich geht davon
aus dass am mittwoch ist auch zu einer
veränderung kommt ich gehe davon aus man
muss dann mal sehen wie viele
hotelbetriebe wie viele pensionen zum
beispiel in baden württemberg in den
letzten monaten investiert haben
die haben ganz präzise hygiene und
abstands konzepte wer in diesen zeiten
in einem hotel ist der wird auf abstand
gehalten mit ganz großem aufwand und dem
wird jetzt gesagt nachdem sie sich über
wochen und monate vorbereitet haben auf
die urlauber aus deutschland die im
schwarzwald oder am bodensee urlaub
machen wollen
die sollen jetzt nicht kommen diese
weindorf sagen aktionismus jetzt dass
das beherbergungs verbot ist ein
unnötiger und auch ein wirtschaftlich
schädlicher aktionismus wir müssen uns
auf die wirklichen risiken konzentrieren
und der kollege von den grünen sprach
eben urlauber seien das problem gewesen
in der ersten phase
das problem waren die partys in ischgl
die dürfen natürlich nicht stattfindet
ich glaube da sind wir sofort ein
aber wenn jemand ruhigen familienurlaub
machen will abstand in der pension mit
seinen kindern also bitteschön das ist
unverhältnismäßig und das gefährdet die
akzeptanz der maßnahmen insel gesagt
das nochmal an den herrn luca
weitergeben herr luca das problem sind
eher partys die ausufern familienfeiern
bei denen keine regeln eingehalten
werden wird hier an der falschen stelle
gemaßregelt und werden jetzt hier die
falschen bestraft mit solchen
beherbergungs verboten und ähnlichem
also nochmal die beherbergungs verbot
sind nicht diese woche neu dazugekommen
die haben existiert die sind nur
aktueller geworden
aufgrund der stark gestiegenen im
zehnten vor allem in vielen großstadt
gebieten sicher auch ausgehend in berlin
und dann haben wir leben da die
infektion verschieben drehen jetzt die
kündigung die infektionsherde
wir beschränken und nochmals lindner ist
operativ nicht tätig der er ist ein
bisserl im trockenschwimmen unterwegs
natürlich haben wir den ganzen sommer
den ganzen sommer über mit der
kommunalen familie ganz klar wenn dann
bei welcher insidious wir welche
maßnahmen treten und der altmark richtig
angesprochen münchen hat mit den ersten
maßnahmen allgemeines masken verbot
alkohol ausschank zu späterer stunde
alles das was im umfeld eine verbreitung
des der infektionen begünstigt
eingeschränkt wir kontrollieren jetzt in
den städten über 50 sind die privaten
feste aufziehen und in öffentlichen
räumen auf 25 begrenzt dass wir hier
auch einschränkungen
wir haben kontaktaufnahme mit den
sportverbänden weil wir auch dort
stichwort dritte halbzeit zunehmend
zunahme haben wir haben mit den
kirchlichen organisationen kontakt
aufgenommen auch die ganzen rituellen
dinge wo inspektionen stattfinden und
das zeigt wirkung und ich finde setzt
ein bisschen schade sie haben recht wir
müssen das beherbergungs verbot so
ausgestalten dass es seinen sinn erfüllt
und nicht als gängelung
gängelungen empfunden wird da wird es
gespräche geben müssen aber die
grundintention in der grundintention auf
reisen die nicht notwendig sind aus
einem gebiet wo wir die füße ausbreitung
abend alle sind erstaunt dass wenn die
deutliche zunahme haben positiv
festungen bei asymptomatischen personen
die ihrerseits der lindner ihre kollegen
aus dem bundestag die gar nicht gewusst
haben dass sie infiziert waren und nur
zufällige eigentlich an den positiv test
der 5 also man muss schon ein bisschen
darf nicht so ganz
holzschnittartig sagt man wusste ganz
genau was gefährlich oder nicht geführt
es gibt aus bremen es gibt einen
virologen der durchaus sehr angesehen
und bekanntes jonas schmidt-chanasit der
in der welt jetzt am wochenende noch mal
sagte beherbergungs verbote sind weder
zielgerichtet noch verhältnismäßig es
gibt doch gar nicht ausreichend
kapazitäten um alle menschen vor ihrer
reise zu testen
meyer ja dann lasst uns japan klein das
ist mal der punkt wenn man so etwas
macht dann muss man natürlich die
kapazitäten schaffen
und wenn es nicht möglich ist und man
trotzdem einschränkung gemacht da muss
man den betroffenen helfen
wir haben ja nach dem ersten block down
auch ermöglicht dass die gastronomie
wieder öffnen konnte ab ende april und
mai wir haben erreicht dass durch die
guten konzepte das risiko beschränkt war
und wenn es sich jetzt herausstellen
sollte dass für die gastronomen für die
hoteliers für die restaurantbesitzer
wieder erhebliche neue umsatzeinbrüche
drohen weil menschen verunsichert sind
nicht kommen es sind ja oftmals auch
nicht nur verboten sondern es hat auch
etwas damit zu tun wie sich die
allgemeine stimmung entwickelt dann bin
ich als wirtschaftsminister der meinung
dann müssen wir den betroffenen auch
mehr helfen also das ist ein punkt wir
haben ja die soforthilfen gemacht die
überbrückungshilfen und das ist ein
punkt wo ich sage da dürfen wir die
betroffenen nicht alleinlassen die
gastronomen sind ein teil unserer
gesellschaftlichen und kulturellen
identität und wir möchten nicht dass
diese familien betriebe aufgeben
verschwinden
und wir am ende dann vielleicht nur noch
fast food ketten haben
ich gehe auch manchmal zu einer fastfood
einrichtung wenn sie gerade am weg liegt
aber ich bin halt eben auch sehr froh
wenn ich dieses große vielfältige
angebot sehe und das darf durch krone
nicht zusteht aber genau diese
verunsicherung ist eben auch ein problem
wir haben einen kollegen teilweise der
bis vor kurzem dachte er johann kommt
noch aus der gefahrenzone berlin
steglitz und schon änderte es sich erst
berlin komplett war risikogebiet seinen
urlaub wohlverdiente urlaub in den
herbstferien ist damit ins wasser
gefallen wir wollen mal zu ihm schalten
teilweise aus berlin
möchtest du mal kurz schildern was du
die letzten tage so erlebt hast ja wir
wollten eigentlich zu diesem zeitpunkt
nämlich seit gestern auf amrum sein
nur gibt es vielleicht hunderttausende
mit denen man ein bisschen mehr mitleid
hat als mit mir oder mit anderen bild
kollegen und trotzdem möchte ich einmal
kurz meine geschichte erzählen
wir wollten genau am samstag früh fahren
hatten die fähre gebucht wollten einen
urlaub verbringen einsamkeit also einem
alleinstehenden ferienhaus
ansteckungsgefahr würde ich sagen dort
nahezu null
das ziel wie gesagt war einsamkeit im
urlaub und wir dachten auch eigentlich
bis donnerstag noch das wir erfahren
könnten
denn der willkürlich angesetzten
inzidenz wert der lag noch deutlich
unter 50 im süden berlins wo wir wurden
und dann gab es eben den beschluss dass
schleswig-holstein gesagt hat okay wir
werden jetzt berlin insgesamt setzten
einen gesamten berliner wert an so dass
für uns auch die werte von neukölln von
mitte gelten wohl die partys gefeiert
worden
während ihr auch schon die hände
gewaschen haben bevor uns die kanzlerin
dazu aufgerufen hat und uns an die
regeln gehalten hat selbst seien
unsinnige regel wie zum beispiel dass
unsere sechsjährige tochter auch den
schulhof die maske tragen muss all das
haben wir gemacht damit uns anschließen
der urlaub gestrichen wurde
also da so würde ich sagen dass das sich
nicht ganz so viel freude gerade darüber
habe dass ralf stegner dann im urlaub
auf usedom ist oder dass der schleswig
holsteinischen ministerpräsident daniel
günther
direkt nach beschluss dieser
stellen sich dann mit seinem
gesundheitsminister in den urlaub
verabschiedet hat also die freude
darüber hält sich gerade in grenzen und
ich finde wir haben ja ganz viele
argumente schon gegen dieses
beherbergungs gebot heute abend in
dieser runde gehört ich finde altmaier
hatte die möglichkeit heute abend
einfach einzuräumen
mensch da sind einen schritt zu weit
gegangen das war glücklich lebensfremd
dass nämlich hier heute abend oder
setzen wir zumindest dafür ein dass ich
das mit meinen ministerpräsidenten in
den nächsten tagen zurücknehmen kann so
das gebe ich doch gleich weiter in die
wunde herr altmaier ihre chance ich habe
ja gesagt wir müssen über diese dinge
reden mit den ministerpräsidenten wir
brauchen einheitliche regelungen
ich halte es allerdings auch und das
sage ich hier an dieser stelle für sehr
richtig dass jemand der infiziert ist
nicht verreist und auch nicht in hotels
oder gaststätten oder öffentlichen
einrichtungen sich aufhält er dem modell
weil andere menschen und deshalb muss
man das klären ob jemand infiziert ist
oder nicht aber das muss es muss geklärt
wenn ja zu bekommen da kommen sie mal
für eine fünfköpfige familie habe ich so
von heute habe ich noch ganz am anfang
selbst angesprochen
ich bitte um verständnis dass ich jetzt
nicht kolleginnen und kollegen in der
regierung oder den ländern kritisieren
möchte für dinge für die ich selber
nicht zuständig bin hier ein sagen das
ist irgendwie nicht ganz ich habe da
habe es geplant dass die dass die
unterschiedliche anwendung ein problem
ist ganz zu anfang schon und herr weise
hat doch in einem punkt recht zu anfang
hat man gesagt wir beurteilen in berlin
jeden bezirk für sich neukölln tempelhof
und dann müssen nicht alle anderen
leiden für diese bezirke mit den
infektionen
dann hat man allerdings festgestellt
dass es da auch widerstand gab und dann
hat man gesagt nie wir bilden jetzt ein
gesamtwert für die stadt berlin
insgesamt weil man dachte dann ist man
noch weit von den 50 weg und als von
landeschef sich erreicht hat da haben
andere wieder gesagt ja und jetzt müssen
die in einem in einem bequemen viertel
für die anderen mithaften ich finde man
kann die maßstäbe nicht einfach während
des geschehens willkürlich verändern und
aber das mit recht in einem punkt recht
was mich persönlich sehr enttäuscht war
wir haben an
geboten zu helfen dass die
gesundheitsämter in berlin ihre arbeit
machen können indem die bundeswehr mit
einspringt und hilft dass die
infektionsketten nachvollzogen werden
können das haben die allermeisten
bezirke in berlin auch angenommen
das muss man hier sagen aber es gab zwei
bezirke die haben gesagt wir wollen die
bundeswehrsoldaten hier nicht sehen ohne
dass sie sicherstellen konnten
dass sie diese nachverfolgbarkeit
gewährleisten können und das halte ich
ehrlich gesagt verantwortlich und noch
eine bitte vielleicht hat man ja sie
haben völlig recht dass sie die
entscheidung nicht alleine treffen
können aber sie können ja zumindest
heute abend mit einem aus dieser runde
dass sie sich dafür einsetzen dass
dieses beherbergungs gebot dieses jahr
teilweise wirklich irrsinnige bewerbung
ist verbot zurück genommen wird dass die
ministerpräsidenten das und hoffentlich
nicht erst nachdem alle herbstferien in
neun bundesländern vorbei sind wirklich
zurücknehmen und wieder lebensnahe
politik machen
noch einmal ich schätze diese runde sehr
und ich bin auch gerne der einladung
gefolgt aber ich bitte herzlich um
verständnis
das war's der bundesminister oder ein
anderer bundesminister in einer runde
mit kollegen oder ministerpräsidenten
diskutiert und vorbereitet das können
wir und es dürfen wir nicht in
öffentlichen sendungen diskutieren am
ende wird es eine große kakophonie und
wir werden mehr schaden anrichten als
wir gut machen
wir haben eine offene diskussion geführt
jeder hat die argumente vernommen und
kennt sie und nun ist es aufgabe der
politik eine gute lösung zu finden ich
kann mir die in der einen wie in der
anderen richtung vorstellen aber es gibt
viele fragen die beantwortet werden
müssen und es gibt probleme die gelöst
werden müssen und dass es unsere
hausaufgaben kann ja nur an die
regierungen appellieren zu vernunft und
verhältnismäßigkeit zurückzukehren
wir berichten familien dass jetzt der
urlaub in mecklenburg vorpommern aus
berlin kommend storniert werden muss
aber dieselben familien können von
berlin aus auf reisen ins europäische
ausland und können da urlaub machen ich
glaube auch kreta ist gegenwärtig kein
risikogebiet in das man ausreißen könnte
mit last minute urlaub aber im
hochschwarzwald oder in mecklenburg
vorpommern ist man nicht erwünscht das
kann man niemandem erklären bringen
und das ist auch in thüringen jaja darf
man das kann man nicht erklären weil
dahinter auch keine echte rationalität
steht und ich glaube wir sind ein paar
maßnahmen angesprochen worden
öffentlicher gesundheitsdienst muss
verbessert werden
wir brauchen eine test strategie für
alle insbesondere für diejenigen die mit
besonders gefährdeten menschen
zusammenarbeiten müssen stichwort alten
jäger ein wir haben ja schon eine
testfahrt ägidius worum geht es im monat
werden muss nur um sie muss nur
umgesetzt wir haben schon wendet er muss
nur umgesetzt werden wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass massenveranstaltungen wo es
unkontrolliert das infektionsgeschehen
gibt dass das unterbunden wird jetzt ist
nicht die zeit für ganz große hochzeit
feiern jetzt ist auch nicht die zeit für
für clubbing bei aller sympathie und
dann ist es möglich dass mit hygiene
abstand maske auch eine familie aus
berlin zb in baden württemberg urlaub
machen kann und letzter gedanke altmaier
in allen ehren dass sie helfen wollen
wieder mit öffentlichem geld nur wir
müssen noch irgendwann erkennen selbst
die viertgrößte volkswirtschaft der welt
kann das wirtschaftliche leben nicht auf
dauer auf pump aufrechterhalten
also brauchen wir regeln und brauchen
wir verfahren die es ermöglichen so viel
öffentliches und wirtschaftliches leben
zu erhalten
trotz gesundheitsschutz allen mit
gesundheit sie haben gerade eingebrochen
und zwar ins ausland reisen kann und
natürlich auch aus dem ausland aus
risikogebieten zurückkommen kann nach
deutschland genauso wie man aus dem
risiko berlin als risikogebiet berlin
nach münchen beispielsweise fliegen kann
und genau da steht jetzt mein kollege
wolfgang ranft und hat mal so beobachtet
wie mit reiserückkehrern aus dem
risikogebiet im ausland umgegangen wird
und wie mit denen risiko reisenden aus
dem deutschen inland verfahren wird
erzähle uns doch mal ja jetzt
überraschend viel los am flughafen
münchen nachts um halb zwölf halb elf an
einem sonntagabend also gelandet ist
gerade eben eine maschine aus madrid
die leute konnten sich frei bewegen bis
sie zum gepäck bis zur gepäckausgabe
gekommen sind ab da werden sie
zwangsweise weitergeleitet zur
teststation wer dort ein
negativen test vorweisen kann darf
sofort nach draußen
die anderen müssen einen test machen für
die bedeutet dass dann bis zum ergebnis
auf jeden fall in quarantäne
natürlich nur soweit sie einheimische
sind wenn die spanier sind dann wird es
für sie schwierig weil die bekommen
offiziell kein hotel in münchen gelandet
ist ebenfalls eine maschine aus berlin
alle fluggäste können einfach
ungehindert das terminal verlassen keine
kontrolle kein test was sie allerdings
auch nicht bekommen ist ein hotelzimmer
in münchen oder eine jugendherberge oder
ein campingplatz soweit es sich um
berliner handelt die münchner dürfen
nach hause fahren müssen nicht in
quarantäne
die berliner könnten allerdings auch bei
einem freund unter kommen und dort
übernachten das wird dann nicht
kontrolliert ich sag mal so wenn herr
altmaier ich weiß nicht was in seinem
passt jetzt genau drin steht das
saarland die heimatgemeinde im saarland
oder berlin
wenn er aus berlin mit dem flugzeug hier
ankäme und dann zu einem hotel fährt in
dem unseren vorweist was der ktg
kontrollieren sollen nämlich den
herkunftsort dann würde unter umständen
einfach ein hotelzimmer bekommen bänder
der saarländische heimatgemeinde
drinsteht erfahrungen berichten ich war
am samstag außerhalb von berlin in einem
anderen bundesland und da ist gefragt
worden von wo kommen sie jetzt genau und
habe ich ja ich komme aus berlin
dann müssen sie einen test vorweisen
sagte ich ja das wusste ich und das habe
ich auch ermöglicht und der test ist
negativ und ich hatte eben glück dass
mein test ausgewertet worden ist und
dass es rechtzeitig geklappt hat ich bin
allerdings losgefahren mittags in meinem
auto ohne zu wissen ob der test positiv
oder negativ ist und hätte unter
umständen das risiko gehabt dann noch
einmal die ganze strecke aber wir wissen
für bundestagsabgeordnete also für
politiker gab es ja auch schon aus
berlin-mitte kommen aus dem risikogebiet
kommen
sonderregeln und ausnahmeregelungen aber
dennoch noch mal ich würde es gern weil
ich kann nur sagen um deutlich zu machen
dass die in dem hotel wo ich war sehr
genau wussten wie sie fragen müssen und
dass die regeln dann auch
gehalten worden sind weiß auch können
aber dennoch berichtet der kollege vom
münchner flughafen dass es offenbar
gefährlicher ist aus spanien zu kommen
möglicherweise infiziert mit corona als
aus berlin zu kommen das will ich noch
mal weiter geben an sie herr lindner
das würde ich noch mal gern weitergeben
an sie zeigt es diesen irrsinn der
regelung also dass da willkürlich etwas
eingeführt wird dann aber nur teilweise
kontrolliert wieder mal ja wir brauchen
auch dort ein einheitliches vorgehen ich
bin generell dafür dass man zb bei der
rückkehr aus dem ausland also mindestens
temperatur misst oder oder anderes macht
hat man ja schon ein erster hinweis ich
persönlich würde auch jetzt gegenwärtig
nicht zu raten im ausland urlaub zu
machen das wäre nun wirklich eine
touristische aktivität die man
einschränken kann
da bin ich durchaus der meinung dass das
nicht zwingend notwendig sein muss zumal
ich in risikogebiete herr stegner noch
mal an sie weitergegeben der kollege hat
eben vom münchner flughafen berichtet
dass urlauber oder reisende die aus dem
risiko gebiet aus dem europäischen
ausland kamen sofort getestet wurden
oder nachts es gefragt worden wohingegen
die risiko reisenden nennen wir sie
jetzt mal so aus berlin nicht getestet
oder gefragt wurden zeigt dass ihrer
meinung nach auch so ein bisschen diesen
irrsinn der neuen regelung
es ist schwer das zu erklären wenn wir
keine einheitlichkeit haben auf der
anderen seite ist das risiko innerhalb
deutschlands generell geringer als
anderswo
und deswegen glaube ich schon dass wir
nicht wir müssen dabei ansetzen dass das
was an maßnahmen erfolgt auch mit dem
problem zu tun hat und wir lernen auch
jetzt heute schon den ganzen abend das
problem ist nicht dass verizon soll das
problem ist dass menschen nicht an
regeln halten also muss man die stärker
kontrollieren und die zur verantwortung
ziehen die regeln brechen und sich an
die wenn wir uns an die dinge halten
denn die sich alle halten müssen dann
haben wir kein problem mit deutscher und
deswegen glaube ich werde das mit dem
bewerbungs verbot sich ändern müssen und
bei den partys hätten stärker
einschreiten müssen das ist die
konsequenz wer sich nicht verantwortlich
verhält muss dafür zur verantwortung
gezogen werden und nicht alle anderen
dürfen bestraft werden
denn ich darf ein
nicht vergessen darüber haben wir heute
noch nicht so sehr gesprochen wir hatten
in deutschland relativ viel akzeptanz
die das demonstriert haben in berlin es
war eine kleine minderheit wenn auch
eine radikale wenn wir die regelung
nicht erklärbar halten dann werden wir
die akzeptanz verlieren und dann wird es
deutlich gefährlicher als momentan in
deutschland ist deutschland ist immer
noch im vergleich zu anderen ländern
sehr viel besser dran aus vielerlei
gründen und deswegen sage ich noch mal
die dinge schwierig sein die muss man
unterbinden das reisen gehört
normalerweise nicht dazu erst recht
nicht wenn sich hotels und pensionen an
die bestimmungen halten das tun sie ja
weitgehend und natürlich muss man leute
die sich nicht an die bestimmung hat
noch darauf hinweisen so das ist der
teil den wir alle miteinander lernen
müssen corona eignet sich nicht für
profilierungs wettbewerbe und auch nicht
dafür dass wir die dinge möglichst
kompliziert machen und sonderregeln für
politiker soll es möglichst auch nicht
geben das kann man auch schwer erklären
also ich glaube insgesamt gleiche regeln
für alle
die wichtigen dinge einhalten dann gehen
die zahlen nicht hoch und das ist glaube
ich das was wir tun können und tun
sollten das verstehen alle bürgerinnen
und bürger politik kann immer nur
erfolgreich sein wenn sie das was sie
macht auch den menschen erklären kann
und das muss das haupt gesichtspunkt
sein herr altmaier findet aktuell an
profilierungs wettbewerb statt und
sollte nicht vielleicht doch noch mal
mehr augenmerk auf die bestehenden
regeln gelegt werden die jetzt vor dem
beherbergungs verbot schon bestanden und
die durchsetzung stichwort auch noch mal
groß familienfeiern da gibt es in
baden-württemberg bei ihnen herr luca
einen fall in esslingen wo die behörden
die stadt selbst sagt das ist
zurückzuführen auf 34 familien muss man
da nicht noch mal genauer hinschauen
eben bei solchen familien freunden und
ich muss man hinschauen und ich würde ja
am wochenende auch irgendwo nicht eine
feier in geschlossenen räumen erlebt
aber einen autokorso einer größeren
familienhochzeit und ich hatte auch den
eindruck ich habe keine masken gesehen
aber viele fröhliche gesichter die
fröhlichkeit ist ja auch etwas sehr
schönes aber die hygienevorschriften
müssen eingehalten werden
das muss generell durchgesetzt werden
und nicht nur bei familien
feierlichkeiten auch für partys jeder
art bei after work partys und was es
alles gibt es kann man durchführen wenn
es richtig organisiert ist und zweitens
wir müssen erreichen eben
dass wir auch aufklären ich habe erlebt
dass ganz viele menschen gesagt haben
okay wir bleiben jetzt mal zu hause
während des schattens als die politik
quer über alle parteien hinweg gesagt
hat bleibt jetzt mal zu hause und macht
keine aktivitäten da sind wir weit davon
entfernt das brauchen wir jetzt nicht
aber ich würde mir schon mal wünschen
dass wir imstande werden den menschen
vielleicht auf einem blatt din a4 einmal
zu sagen das sind die vier oder fünf
wichtigsten ansteckungsquelle das sind
die vier oder fünf wichtigsten maßnahmen
wir sollten nicht glauben wenn wir hier
bei ihnen in der bild-redaktion oder in
einer zeitung oder in einer
nachrichtensendung darüber reden dass
wir damit alle bürger gleichermaßen
erreichen
die bürger zu 95 prozent sind bereit
sich verantwortlich zu verhalten
aber wir müssen ihnen auch klare signale
geben was wir von ihnen erwarten klare
signale ich würde gern noch eine ganz
schnelle abschlussrunde machen und mit
ihnen anfangen herr lacher was würden
sie denn den bürgern raten jetzt in den
herbstferien noch verreisen in
deutschland bleiben immer eigenen in den
eigenen vier wänden
was kann man denn aktuell noch raten
also erst einmal sind ja nicht alle sind
städten mit risikogebieten zweitens
glaube ich ist das reisen den
herbstferien meine sagte jetzt auch
etwas überbewertet ich glaube schon dass
man in der verhältnismäßigkeit
selbstschutz und schutz von dritten auch
abwägen kann lasse ich mich etwas ein
was sich selber nicht im blick habe
ansonsten gilt das einhalten der regeln
tatsächlich kontakte so weit es möglich
ist auch zurückzuführen abstandsgebot
hygiene die erste jetzt auch zunehmend
lüften sich an die regeln halten und wir
als öffentliche seite und das tun wir
und das möchte ich schon noch sagen
warum waren mir so erfolgreich weil wir
die schnellsten von allen waren weil wir
maßnahmen schnell getroffen haben
vielleicht ist jetzt auch diese
reaktivierung des beherbergungs verbotes
eine dieser schnell maßnahmen die
jetzt auch noch mal in der ausprägung
noch mal genauer anschauen müssen aber
sie geben mir recht wir brauchen schon
eine rückversicherung dass infizierte
sich nicht auf reisen begeben eine
irgendwie geartete kontrolle braucht man
auch wenn die jetzige form nicht
geeignet sein ansonsten müssen wir uns
an die hygiene an die aare
wir haben und was dann glauben sie
stehen nach wie vor felsenfest hinter
dem beherbergungs verbot erstickt gerade
eben gehört dass das reisen in den
herbstferien überbewertet ist was sagen
sie dazu sind im urlaub und was würden
sie den deutschen aktuell raten sollte
man sich noch trauen oder besser zu
hause bleiben
also ich finde viele menschen haben das
wirklich verdient sie haben hart
gearbeitet zum teil hatten überhaupt
keinen urlaub übrigens weil sie sich
kümmern mussten um ihre kinder und die
kitas geschlossen waren und vieles
andere mehr menschen jetzt zu sagen
reist nicht das finde ich falsch sie
müssen sich nicht ins ausland reisen da
wäre ich behandle aber in deutschland
kann man urlaub machen
die hotels und gaststätten und pensionen
halten sich an die virtuelle aber egal
ob im urlaub oder zu hause rücksicht um
sich vor sich das sind die dinge die
gelten müssen
man muss rücksicht auf seine mitmenschen
nehmen wenn man das tut dann stehen auch
keine großen gefahren und die die keine
rücksicht nehmen die müssen zur
verantwortung gezogen
was glauben sie wie lange hält das
beherbergungs verbot noch bis mittwoch
es wird auch klagen dagegen geben weil
die maßnahmen des staates müssen
verhältnismäßig sein
es kann nicht sein dass eine regierung
entscheidet auch mit edlen motiven es
muss immer faktisch geprüft werden ist
es eine wirklich geeignete erforderliche
damit verhältnismäßige maßnahme also
wird wirklich ein problem gelöst oder
wird nur freiheit eingeschränkt
präventiv so aus einem gefühl heraus
oder aus einem edlen läden absicht
heraus das ist nicht massstab
staatlichen handelns und wenn die
regierung ist nicht korrigiert bin ich
interessiert zu wissen wie das
verwaltungsgerichte beurteilen werden
von ihnen haben wir gehört man ist auf
jeden fall dabei das zu korrigieren sie
haben es nicht in der hand herr altmaier
aber sie versuchen auf jeden fall
einfluss auszuüben
wir sind doch seien sechs monaten dabei
dass wir ständig überfüllt
welche maßnahmen haben wir ergriffen
wirken sie müssen wir schärfere
ergreifen können wir andere wieder
lockern und aussetzen im moment ist
übrigens nicht der zeitpunkt für große
lockerungen
aber es muss natürlich immer überprüft
werden ob etwas wirkt und ich will nur
zu dem bewerbungs verbot sagen das ist
ja damals es ist ja nicht für ganz
deutschland erlassen es ist dort lassen
wo die hotspots inne wo die zahl der
infektionen so groß sind
und damals war der grund dafür dass alle
ministerpräsidenten gesagt haben wenn in
gütersloh
die zahl der infektionen steigt dann ist
es ausreichend dort beschränkungen zu
machen und nicht alle 83 millionen
menschen in deutschland damit zu
behelligen so und das war damals auch
richtig und gut heute haben wir die
situation dass die zahl der hotspots
jeden tag sich in rasender
geschwindigkeit vermehrt und ausdehnt
und deshalb müssen wir diese lösen und
müssen die frage beantworten wie können
wir denn tatsächlich und die neue
infektionen bekämpfen und gleichzeitig
die freiheit der menschen möglich sag
mal ein ganz großes im einzeln dann
führt das weiß ich nicht aber ich hoffe
dass es einheitlich ist und dass jeder
bürger dann weiß woran er ist herr
altmaier kurze nachfrage nochmals bitte
kurze antwort glauben sie dann selbst
dass das beherbergungs verbot den
mittwoch überlebt oder gekippt wird
der glaube ist etwas für den lieben gott
und für das persönliche gebet und im
übrigen bietet ist nicht zu spekulieren
wir werden am mittwoch eine sehr
verantwortliche sitzung haben und dann
wird entschieden werden welche maßnahmen
wie beschlossen und verändert werden das
war diplomatisch politiker spreche frau
harte letzte frage an sie unterstützen
sie klagen ganz gehört es wird klagen
leben es gibt auch einzeln der
gastronomen die schon angekündigt haben
gegen die sperrstunde zu klagen
unterstützen sie auch mit dem verband
diese klagen ja also es ist bei uns ja
auch föderalismus die landesverbände
sind ja vor ort auch gefordert stehen im
dialog die verordnungen sind ja
unterschiedlich aus das muss man sich
anschauen
also ich würde mir jetzt einfach für die
kommende woche wünschen dass man aus dem
was jetzt die letzten tage passiert ist
gelernt hat und gehe auch davon aus dass
nicht alle verordnungen hier in der
juristischen überprüfung standhalten
werden also keine frage wenn es eine
branche gibt und auch unsere gäste wir
wollen alle nicht mehr das was wir im
märz april mai erlebt haben ja viele
betriebe waren acht bis zwölf wochen
geschlossen und die menschen im land
haben sich gefreut als die cafés
restaurants wieder geöffnet wurden und
sie reißen konnten innerhalb
deutschlands ja und das dürfen wir alle
nicht gefährden deswegen klar wir müssen
die schutzmaßnahmen konsequente umsetzen
alle miteinander
aber es muss mehr klarheit rein kommen
bei allem respekt von föderalismus und
ob man jetzt bundesweit bußgeld auf 50
oder 250 euro festgelegt ja das sollen
die verantwortlichen politiker
entscheiden aber wenn ich hier zu
schnell fahre in berlin
kriege ich eine geldbuße die sie den
bayern genau so aus also es ist schwer
erklärbare halb alles im klein kleiner
wieder unterschiedlich ist und ich
glaube der rechtsrahmen muss definiert
werden aber jedes bundesland kann
abhängig von seinem individuellen
infektionsgeschehen natürlich sagen wir
brauchen weitere beschränkungen oder wir
reden jetzt über die öffnung von
diskotheken wie in sachsen anhalt ab
erst november das meines wissens noch
immer geplant ist herr schuhbeck sie
haben jetzt das letzte wort was wünschen
sie sich mit blick auf den gipfel am
mittwoch auf dem noch mal diese
maßnahmen auch überdacht und
möglicherweise angepasst werden sollen
also ich möchte mir sagen wie wir diese
runde sehr gut gefallen dass eigentlich
alles gesagt worden was wichtig ist
angst machen ist das eine aber jetzt
glaube ich ist die zeit auch wieder mit
den leuten zu sprechen dass jeder dort
mit macht das was jetzt gesagt worden
ist und dann kommen wir wesentlich
weiter und wo sie am mittwoch
entscheiden das werden wir dann schon
erfahren und ich drücke ihnen die daumen
dass die richtigen entscheidungen
getroffen werden und zwar dass man lust
hat dort mitzumachen nicht dass man nur
wieder schimpft die meisten schimpfen
komplette her und machen nichts also
sind sowieso mitmachen dann kommt
wesentlich mehr aus also das hört sich
auf jeden fall sehr geduldig an
das sind bescheidene wünsche die damit
gegeben werden vielen dank für diese
runde
das waren die richtigen fragen
sonntagabend und uns gibt's wie immer
auch nächsten sonntag wieder einen
schönen abend wünsche ich noch
[Musik]